[Musique]
parlons d'une des vidéos les plus viral
apparu sur le radar des décrypteurs
depuis le début de cette pandémie
son titre pandemic durée de 26 minutes
il s'agit en fait d'un extrait d'un
documentaire qui devrait paraître cet
été
l'objectif de ce documentaire dévoilé un
plan secret qui se cacherait derrière la
pandémie de communes 19 passé au peigne
fin par ma collègue bouchra wathiq cette
vidéo qui était banide youtube est
truffé de faussetés et d'affirmation
trompeuse installé toute la vidéo repose
sur une entrevue avec cette scientifique
la biologiste américaine du lit mikovits
le problème c'est son manque de
crédibilité
dès les premières secondes du
documentaire madame mikovits s'est
présenté comme une des chercheuses les
plus brillants de sa génération
pourtant elle s'est surtout fait
connaître en étant la co auteur d'une
étude sur le syndrome de fatigue
chronique qui a dû être rétractée après
la découverte de failles majeures par
une dizaine d'autres laboratoires
dans le documentaire madame mikovits se
déforme aussi les raisons de son
congédiement d'un institut de recherche
du nevada dans pandémique
il est suggéré qu'elle était renvoyée
pour avoir révélé des secrets sur
l'industrie pharmaceutique est arrêté
pour la réduire au silence
pourtant des documents légaux montre
qu'elle a illégalement récupéré des
biens qui appartenait à l'institut qui a
poursuivi la biologiste pour bris de
contrat et appropriation frauduleuse de
secrets commerciaux et dans le contexte
de la pandémie actuelle à travers madame
mikovits le documentaire prétend que le
port d'un masque et l'utilisation de
désinfectants serait dangereux cette
affirmation sider le virologue benoit
barbeau qui rappelle que le port du
masque sert d'abord à éviter de
contaminer les autres et que masque ne
nous isole pas complètement de tout ce
qui circule autour de nous alors qu on
est constamment bombardés par des
bactéries et des virus
cette affirmation a d'ailleurs valu à ce
documentaire d'être retirée de la
plateforme facebook et en passant la
sortie de ce documentaire coïncide tiens
tiens avec la publication d'un livre de
madame mikovits s'intituler la peste de
la corruption
un livre coécrit avec militants anti
vaccins
interdits d'entrée en australie en 2017
pour une analyse plus détaillée
je vous suggère fortement la lecture de
l'article de ma collègue bouchra wathiq
disponible sur notre site web ou dans
notre groupe facebook
n'oubliez pas aussi de regarder notre
émission diffusée les samedis et
dimanches salut
[Musique]